so feel that I have to do something with
my white pieces as well the handshake is
there
let's go
or not
there we go E4
and now it is magnus's turn to shadow of
his pieces
and that was three bottles of water my
counting skills not up to par this early
in the morning and Carlson responds much
like yesterday's game with colors
reversed with E5 and something tells me
that Prague will not be essaying the
Four Knights defense in this game
it will be the Italian I'm pretty sure
that Prague was for the Italian exactly
Bishop C4 on the board
might have sex and of course the fried
lever with Knight G5 has fallen out of
fashion product going Mainline with D3
yes and now A4 immediately okay this is
a slight surprise usually white plays C3
or short Castle first
and uh
the main point is
I believe pretty clear try to surprise
European as quickly as possible Magnus
is not posing definitely he hasn't
expected the movie for to happen so
early
an A4 has been essentially the sin
quanon of how top GMS have played the
Italian recently this move appears in
almost every Italian game but it usually
appears much later Peter I think this is
what you're saying it usually appears
after white has played C3 and often
developed the knight from B1 so A4 as
early as mu5 it's not unheard of what is
the idea other than the pure surprise
value of delaying the move C3 as Magnus
responding in very conventional fashion
there with D6 it's probably going to put
a knight on C3 potentially somehow I'm
skeptical about that
yes I think that uh the whole point was
of A4 to try to provoke black of
deciding already of going A6 or A5
however magnus's choice is what I'm also
preferring simply to stay flexible not
show your cards yet and after D6 short
Castle yeah proxies yes I'm not
interested yet on advancing my iPhone it
was just a slight teaser and I'm kind of
asking you yes please decide whether you
want to put that app on as quickly as
possible and we've seen so much New Life
breathed into the Italian which is one
of the oldest if not the oldest opening
in modern chess it has been played
regularly at the top level since the
1600s but in the old days both sides
would automatically castle kingside in
the old days white would play C3
followed by D4 but recently we've seen a
crop of games where black tries to go H6
and G5 and actually delays Castle in
kingside instead going for the quick
attack on White's King side but often
Peter that attack is a lot stronger when
white already has a Pawn on H3 because
that pawn acts as a hook for Black's
g-pawn once it reaches G4 in this
particular version H6 followed by G5
just doesn't seem to be congruent uh
with Matt what Magnus wants out of this
game which I think is a solid setup with
the black pieces
for sure yes the question is on the
other hand that what is his move does he
spend the tempo on H6 making sure that
white won't be jumping Bishop G5
that's one question another question
that if and Magnus goes A5 yeah I wanted
to highlight that if he is not pushing
his a pawn
he goes for castles then he has to be
confronted with Bishop G5 so Magnus
decides to stay flexible and after A5
plug immediately blitzes out the move
Bishop C1 to E3 that was his idea
against Black's A5 setup that's a big
move of course the bishop could come out
to G5 instead it comes out to E3
offering an exchange and this is a very
thematic Exchange in the Italian if
black trades what does white get in
return well the downside is clear white
gets the doubled pawns but in return
white gets pressure down the f file uh
The Rook on F1 is going to be very happy
combining with the bishop on C4 and in
some situations of course the knight
from F3 could jump either to G5 but more
commonly from H4 it seeks uh a nice post
on F5 black of course can do the same
thing black can respond with Bishop E6
but white is under no obligation to
exchange the Bishops in the same manner
and white can play the move Knight B1 to
D2 keeping the tension we actually might
see all of these moves on the board
Carlson has exchanged but instead of
Bishop E6 he has castled kingside right
into the teeth of White's potential
attack
thank you
it's somewhat surprising for me yeah
Magnus so let's just go slowly Magnus
captures on E3 ftxcc castles I wanted to
give a kind of uh explanation that maybe
the reason why Prague has not played the
standard C2 C Series that he might want
to develop his Knight to C3 however he
goes for the conventional Knight B2
Magnus blitzes out the typical night
maneuver rerouting that night to G6
that's the perfect square for black
snide also making sure that all the
ideas with Knight H4 won't be so uh
dangerous and black is also setting up
some c6d5 ideas trying to block that
Bishop on C4
now the big question however if you know
that Magnus wants to play Knight G6
stopping Knight H4 then there is the
question why aren't we able to do that
immediately
so Knight H4
in this position jump on the opportunity
train because once the Knight reaches G6
I mean you can play Queen E1 followed by
Knight H4 but it won't come with the
same effect if you play Knight H4 here
what I like about that move is Knight G6
of course can be met with Knight to F5
and obviously the Knight and F5 can be
chopped off black and play Bishop takes
F5 but that's a pretty big concession
you're giving away your light Square
Bishop which means that White's control
over the A2 G8 diagonal is now
uncontested and can only be contested by
the c65 idea so without the bishop black
often struggles to maintain the same
level of control in the center I think
that Knight H4 might be prag's most
testing response
I'm with you
yes somehow so it fits perfectly to
White's previous play he has already
doubled his pawns with the clear idea of
trying to grab the initiative with
Knight H4
he knows exactly that you give black
couple of moves Knight G6 c6d5 and black
will be the one fighting for the center
and also for the
upper hand then white spawn structure
will suddenly tell white has to be
energetic and Knight H4 on the board
and Magnus immediately responding with
C7 C6 the idea that we have talked about
here at length preparing D5 in some
situations preparing to deploy the queen
to B6 and attacking uh that E3 Pawn
which could become vulnerable later on
in the middle game and of course Carlson
keeping his Knight on E7 in order to
take the sting out of Knight F5 Knight
F5 in this position would lead to a very
unfavorable exchange for white because
it would relinquish White's control over
the center and allow black to push D5
and establish ideal control over the
center White's attack in the meantime
while it's fledgling attack would go
absolutely nowhere with that pawn on F5
blocking White's control over the f-file
this is out of the question
yes one thing that however we have to
address the typical action sacrifice
look takes F6 and Magnus is kind of
provoking it that gives me the feeling
that clearly he anticipates the move he
feels like in this exact position I
don't have to fear it but since Prague
is not posing I believe we should be
talking about this action sacrifice look
takes F6 GTX F6 Queen H5 usually this is
the way black plays the move D5 white
falls back with the bishop to B3 and
long terms there is very serious idea
with the Rook F1 going after Black's
King but Prague has fed like Nono Magnus
is trying to provoke me for it
um probably white is not yet ready and
he plays according to the demands of The
Possession he goes for Queen E1 instead
and Rook takes up sex has to be kept in
mind as long as Black's Knight remains
on E7 and it likely will remain on E7
for the time being this is the whole
Crux of magnus's strategy if you rush
the move Knight G6 uh we've already been
down that rabbit hole white plays Knight
F5 and achieves the kind of Ideal setup
on the king side Prague is aiming
directly for G3 once the queen reaches
G3 Rook takes F6 will be a direct threat
Black's King could slide over to h8 but
Prague is not trying to do anything fast
he is accumulating his pieces on the
king side that is the first phase of any
attack you need to actually get your
pieces to the right area of the board
nothing in the Italian happens within
two or three moves this is a gradual
process and a big question Peter is
whether and when Magnus will push D5
because the drawback of the move D5 is
obvious it weakens the E5 pawn and queen
G3 potentially will come with even
greater effect
yes Queenie one is a very nice little
touch I also
somehow remember that in this type of
possessions often the little quiet
movies to HD seemingly doing nothing
giving a Tempo is also a very typical
way of reinforcing the idea of going
Queen G3
in certain situations it's kind of nice
to control the G4 Square
but for the moment it is Magnus who has
to think about how to handle the
position I'm loving the choice of Prague
for the fact that Magnus has tremendous
experience in the Italian in different
structures but exactly this very
specific one that white has kept the
pawn on C2 and white was able to go for
a very quick Knight hitch for followed
by Queen E1 Queen G3
feel like this is a very fresh position
Prague has done a Monumental job this
Tournament of sensing in which type of
position his opponent will feel most
comfortable most uncomfortable and when
you're talking about players like ikar
Nakamura and Magnus Carlson that is very
very hard to do against icaro uh he
responded uh to the move 1c4 with a
principled E5 against Magnus in their
first classical game prognan to play the
English opening himself and he did
manage to put serious pressure on Magnus
Carlson's choice of setup now he decides
to opt for E4 and an opening that he
himself is more comfortable with and
more experienced with which makes a lot
of sense because in the rapid time
control one of the most important things
is not only objective Advantage but also
to get a position that you feel
comfortable with like putting on you
know an old pair of jeans you know what
to expect and I really like prague's
opening choice he's built up a little
advantage on the clock as well and a big
decision here coming up for Magnus
very big decision it's clear that his
last two moves 97 C6 had one clear
intention of going D5
and he is posing he hasn't been blitzing
out the move D5 while we are waiting for
Magnus to make up his mind
we can maybe just quickly check what
happens after D5 Bishop B3 so white
falls back with the bishop you already
mentioned that yes white will come with
Queen G3 targeting that pawn on E5 using
the pin on the G file against the king
of uh going for duct takes F6 ideas as
well and the most natural developing
move Bishop E6 might run into Queen GC
with this double attack when black might
be forced to move away that knight from
F6 to D7 certainly something which you
don't want to do and white can continue
to accumulate his pieces with moves like
Rook a to E1 and potentially could
strike at the center himself with a
well-timed D3 D4 that would lead to
massive tension in the center and lo and
behold we do have D5 it should be three
on the board but Carlson responding with
Queen to D6 occupying the square that
was left vacant by Black's previous move
the queen moves up in order to protect
the Knight laterally and to protect the
E5 Pawn it's a very logical move on the
surface but the drawback Peter is that
after Queen to G3 as we see Prague
leaning over the board I think he might
be sensing that this is an opportunity
to grab the initiative Queen G3 poses
serious threats against Black's Queen
which is undefended and that idea I
pointed out a little bit earlier D3 D4
turns from an abstract concept into a
concrete threat
wow yes this is very interesting so
after Queen G3 black has to deal with
the situation let's just one time try
the most natural move Knight G6
white has even different options Knight
F5 even in this construction maybe
Knight G6 is also possible let me just
highlight this transformation of
structure I think G6 HD G6 e takes D5 C
takes D5 Knight F3 attacking that pawn
black has to go locate and white flows
it up with Knight G5 followed by Queen
H4 and suddenly look takes F6 Queen H7
check ideas are coming
super dangerous stuff
and it all starts with queen G3 that
Queen's supervising the other pieces and
aiming at the E5 Pawn is it fair to say
that should Prague play the natural
Queen shoe 3 which I'm expecting he will
that Magnus is again trouble is a very
strong word and you know Magnus Carlson
is not often in trouble but let's put it
this way his position seems quite a bit
more uncomfortable after Queen G3
he doesn't have natural moves and the
computer actually highlights that Knight
H5 might be the best it's a very strange
little move because after Queen G5 black
actually has to fall back with the
Knight to F6 and one doesn't get the
feeling like you can afford to lose this
extra tempo
and Magnus in full consultation mode he
feels that this is a very critical
position
what's going down through prague's head
right now it he obviously sees the move
Queen G3 could he be asking himself is
this too good to be true you know does
Magnus have something up his sleeve
because we have the luxury of seeing the
computer assessment of seeing the top
move Prague is sitting there and he's
thinking there's no way that Queen G3 is
as good as it looks well it actually is
as good as it looks and Prague he's been
trusting himself all tournament right he
has been believing in his own ability to
approach every position in a better and
Superior way than even the top players
in the world can he rely on that
confidence here and play Queen G3 in a
timely fashion
I believe he will first of all I also
don't really see any other move for
white yeah it's a kind of the absolute
logical follow-up he has played the move
Knight H4 he has played the move Queen
D1 to E1 with a clear intention of going
with his Queen to G3
is he bothered by this Knight H5 I don't
think that it's such a yeah and it's on
the board
he's played it and if Knight H5 followed
by retracting the Knight back to F6 is
the best that black can do well that is
a pretty bad sign for Carlson because
doing that in any position is difficult
that is admitting that the situation is
undesirable for you that you are
essentially groveling uh for a draw and
that you are at the mercy of your
opponent who can choose to repeat the
position of course I think there's no
way that Prague would repeat uh if
Magnus does in fact play Knight H5 and
Knight F6 but could Carlson play a
calmer move like Rook f8 to EA just
trying to solidify the center and
prepare for the eventuality that white
plays D4
but that move looks very shaky I guess
that rookie with the vulnerable F7 Pawn
the bishop on B3 look on F1 beautifully
eyeing I'm not seeing black going for a
move like this
I agree it doesn't seem to do anything
specific maybe Rook to d8 in order to
protect the queen and and try to take
this thing out of D4 here you're
highlighting e takes D5 and E4 carving
open the a2ga diagonal and obviously if
black plays D4 everything collapses the
knight from D2 jumps into C4 and wins
the E5 pawn and man I mean this is how
close the situation is from becoming
absolutely critical it seems like
whichever Peter you're leaving something
else exposed if you move the Rook you
leave F7 if you move the Bishop from C8
then you're not addressing the pin along
the h2b8 diagonal this is very
problematic for Magnus
very end we see Magnus immediately in
super concentrating mood he knows
exactly that he can't afford one
inaccuracy
the the reason why it's so unpleasant
for him at the moment that he has played
only the most natural moves so you can't
really
understand while playing the game that
what went wrong one could argue that
maybe against this setup then the move
Knight E7 followed by C6 was too
ambitious but it's such a natural way so
after queen gcina I'm pretty sure that
Magnus will have to spend a lot of time
and has to understand that actually the
move Knight H5 is super ugly but
probably we have I have to play it let's
just quickly check this Knight H5 Queen
G5 so the Black Knight has to fall back
another
the problem for white is it's not so
easy to follow it up with a direct idea
black also has this idea of kicking the
queen away with H6 and once the queen
falls back to GC then again keep on
harassing that Queen you just have to
somehow unbalance the situation you you
can't tolerate that Queen on G3 for too
long well D4 definitely has to be
calculated here but first impressions
after D4 Knight takes E4 Maybe
black is okay although it still feels
like White's initiative there is really
scary I mean the computer is
highlighting a really difficult move
here not Knight takes E4 but Knight F6
to G4 I mean one of those moves that
once it's played yeah it looks kind of
logical because you're eyeing the H2
Pawn but you know try finding the
sequence of moves Knight H5 then Knight
back to F6 and then Knight F6 to G4 that
is a Herculean task for Magnus Carlsen
and these are the variations that might
be circling around his mind right now
definitely as a pawn it also shows that
he feels like he needs some new impulses
this is a very typical common reaction
of uh any top player that you feel like
okay I'm nervous I have to somehow
get some some new feeling for the
position it's not easy yeah he puts that
pawn aside gets ready for new
concentration and is he about to make a
move
not yet hard to say not yet and this is
a 25 plus 10 rapid game so playing
objectively is much more important than
playing quickly you have time we've seen
players successfully spent over 10
minutes per move uh in this time control
because keeping a reasonable position is
so important Prague still has 20 minutes
on his clock and he has made uh even one
minute uh count and go very very far how
will Magnus try to douse the Flames of
White's initiative there are so many
threats here so many problems and the
best news for Prague is that he hasn't
sacrificed anything to get this position
he can play slowly and Magnus uncorking
Knight H5 wow
it is Magnus clearly he understood that
okay I have done all the natural moves
there has to be something in the
position he did spend a lot of time he's
under 50 minutes and it's only move 13
in the game this is uh this is showing
that what an incredible preparation it
was from Prague that he managed to
unbalance unsaturated Magnus right from
the start
Magnus can't relax for for a single
second he's under pressure
man just the the tension in in a good
sense with which Prague plays you know
the pressure that he puts on every
player is is really something else it's
honestly very impressive to watch Prague
blossoming into uh the super Grand
Master that he is and the level that
he's played with for the better part of
the last year but now finally his rating
catches up to his strength now where
will he put his queen queen to G5 is not
the only move the queen could also slide
over to F3 and Carlson's reaction to
that move will likely be the same right
he will drop back to F6 we might see
prognanada repeating the position once
but I find it very hard to believe as I
said earlier that he will not try to
squeeze more from this position than a
draw
I think that knowing Prague he will not
even repeat not once he go he goes for
Queen G5 Knight F6
and he will remain ambitious he just
but okay we talked about this that
Black's only movies Knight F6 according
to computer
not knowing the fact that this is the
the best move there are also some
arguments for G6 trying to make sure
that you kind of control the GC square
and that's what Magnus goes for
great call Peter and G6 I think is a
very sensible move because you're going
to follow this with the move F6 and
you're going to kind of blanket White's
pieces with this uh with these spikes
right these pawns on F6 and G6 which
together are controlling a lot of
important squares and potentially
forcing White's Queen to seek shelter on
H4 Prague might have to move his Knight
back to F3 in order to open up that
little window for the queen on H4
because if you slide the queen up to H6
I could conceive of some lines where
that Queen gets into some trouble that
might be a little bit too audacious and
I think Knight hf3 satisfies the demands
of the position but Prague goes forward
to F5
wow quite quickly he made this decision
I was trying to highlight how do we trap
that Queen on A6 after F6 Queen H6 and
the only way what I find was this look
F7 King h8 98 which would have run into
knight fg6 checkmate yes
just to highlight yeah that what a crazy
construction this is but Prague goes
instantly for Knight F5 this is a move
that if it works out well we will be
saying that it's uh it was a great
choice putting the pressure on Magnus uh
playing quickly on the other hand if
Magnus somehow manages to neutralize
Black's white Initiative for example
Bishop takes F5 it takes F5 and then
maybe King G7 is that possible trying to
make uh some control over the dark
squares let me even put it because I
feel like this is so important takes
takes and if not for them of King G7 I
feel I'm seriously Under Pressure but
King G7 stopping F6 and eventually
setting up some kind of ideas with queen
F6
and White's attack starts to run out of
steam here that's the problem Prague is
really lacking in this position a minor
piece you know a knight on G4 or maybe a
dark squared Bishop so white could play
some sort of accumulating move like Rook
a to E1 for example but if you're
resorting to a move like that that means
that the worst is behind Carlson did
Prague Rush with this move Knight F5
it's a very thematic move it's a
tempting move he is kind of riding the
fumes of his attack but he might have
given up that night a little bit too
early and you know the ostensibly more
reserved Knight F3 I think would have
kept better practical chances Carlson
he seems ready to make his move he can
play F6 but that might be a little bit
too weakening King G7 does seem like the
most precise defensive move and we have
grown accustomed to Magnus finding moves
like King G7 on the regular
yes I also feel on magnus's body
language like he's relieved he feels
like uh all right yes and King G7 on the
board
that is the desired stability for black
and especially we are talking about the
rapid game if you are constantly asked
questions which aren't easy to answer
those are the most unpleasant things now
however Magnus feels like all right I
have shot that Bishop out for goods
because even if White follows up E4 he
takes D5 C takes D5 is still perfectly
good for black covering the dark squares
the Knight on H5 doesn't extremely good
job
and also the idea that eventually black
is really threatening to play Queen F6
because it puts uh kind of a lot of
pressure on the F5 Pawn as well
I feel that this is maybe the first
moment that Magnus is really happy with
his position
and there's a very important tactical
detail let's take a neutral move like C3
just to illustrate after Queen F6
uh or then let me let me play Rook F2 or
that not uh not good enough
I think it does the line still works
after Rook F2 I was gonna say after
Queen F6 Queen G4 in fact Rook F2 I
think makes a lot of sense from White's
perspective you would like to play Queen
G4 you would like to keep the Queens on
the board and ostensibly after Knight
takes F5 E4 wins the night but the issue
is this vulnerable placement of the
queen on G4 Black's Knight can go
forward to E3 but even safer is to go
back to H6 and black gets out of the pin
counter-attacking White's Queen and look
at just the heroic defensive role
exerted by the King on G7 which protects
the queen on F6 and that means you know
the Desperado sacrifice on H5 leads
absolutely nowhere also Queen takes F2
uh and black will emerge with an extra
exchange so this is out of the question
which means Queen F6 is a major
positional threat because if the Queens
go off the board I think that we might
start talking about a slight Advantage
for black in the end game
exactly
yes somehow maybe because Prague rushed
too quickly with Knight F5 did he simply
miss them of King G7 or he did not miss
them of King G7 but he forgot that there
might be a threat from black with Queen
F6 he it could have easily been that he
had forced in the structure because
especially when you make up your mind
quickly you think about the structure
and you think like all right I have all
the time in the world to double my Rooks
on the f file Knight X F5 is never a
problem due to the pin and I'm gonna
insist ongoing F6 if black ever plays
the movie F6 then White Queen just falls
back to G4 and the the king side
structure will be very vulnerable it
everything depends on this wonderful
Queen F6 the source
and Prague has shown an ability to
adjust pretty seamlessly to the new
demands of the position you know is game
against Hikaru Nakamura comes to mind
his first classical game where he was
better throughout uh or his the game in
which he was black he was better
throughout he was pressuring and at some
point Hikaru took over the initiative on
the board and on the clock Prague was
able to take a deep breath gather
himself uh and put together an excellent
defensive display uh to hold the
position he needs to do that here he
might not even be worse on the board I
think it's very important Peter to
clarify probably Prague is not worse
here but the trend of the game we talked
about this yesterday the trend of the
game favors black because Prague was
just attacking he was just paralyzing
black and suddenly he's dealing with a
very nasty positional threat and the
question of him being worse is has
suddenly been raised can he calm himself
down and play an objective patient move
like Rook a to E1
very tough because I also don't know
exactly what does this move really do to
the position okay one yeah why
first question can't black do the same
with Queen F6 what is this difference
apparently no he can't
wow
so now Queen G4 Knight takes F5
E4 Knight H6
and wow just Queen D7
and you take the B7 Pawn but why was
this move
impossible in a different version like
why is The Rook being on E1 necessary to
make this move possible maybe it's
because after Queen H4 you're able to
play Knight Des knight uh
oh apparently Queen Z8
and if you take B7 Knight G4 hits The
Rook on F2 and generates a lightning
attack on the king's side it's the fact
that the Rook on F2 would be really
vulnerable whereas The Rook on E1 would
enable white to exert pressure on black
Center
wow this uh this line basically
illustrates how difficult and complex
this position is
I'm looking at it I still don't fully
understand Peter like why rookie one is
so crucial
my guess is that we might say a queen
trade I think Prague might bite the
bullet and say listen after Queen takes
F6 maybe I can quickly go E4 I find it
hard to believe that white is in big
danger in the end game but obviously an
end game would play right into Magnus
Carlson's biggest strength particularly
in the rapid time control
yeah the move that comes to my mind is
that what happens after E4 it looks like
the maybe the most natural human move if
we see that we can't follow it up with
hook F2 Magnus also leaning back on his
chair he definitely feels that he got
stability and this is what really
matters for him
and the ball is back on prox court
for sure
and the thinking time I think says it
all Prague is now down on the clock gone
is the time advantage that he built up
with his excellent opening preparation I
think it's an encouraging sign that he's
taking his time it means that he senses
that the trend of the game has reversed
in Black's Direction and that it's
important for him to make a stabilizing
move I'm with you Peter I think E4 is
the move most grand Masters would play
in a Blitz game because it's thematic
you connect your Pawns of course you
weaken the F4 square but that doesn't
seem particularly essential
yes fighting for the center making sure
that the bishop
from BC is getting closer to the game it
takes D5 is always an idea then already
the move to K1 will be so much more
natural
it's uh
and Prague goes King H1 all right he
just makes a natural move
okay but Queen F6 is very likely to
follow and Magnus might play that move
fast because he had so much time to
gather his thoughts while Prague was
thinking I feel like Queen F6 forces a
queen trade and then King H1 might
actually be counterproductive because in
the end game in general you want your
king closer to the center
this is the feeling I'm getting that
with King H1 does actually proc signal
that he completely misses Black's
resource with Queen F6
I'm entirely possible yeah I'm I'm
shocked for the fact because of course
thanks to computer we have understood
Queen F6 quite quickly but assuming that
he spent quite a lot of time and he did
not opt for Rook F2 idea we do kf1
that's kind of uh surprising
and Carlson has to find Queen F6 you can
also throw White's Queen away with the
move H6 but Queen F6 is the kind of move
that you do play if you see the move you
play it so the big question for Magnus
is can he calculate past Queen F6 Queen
G4 the key thing to realize is that the
pawn on F5 can be captured because you
can unpin in the manner that we have
previously described by dropping the
Knight away to H6 and counter-attacking
white screen if Magnus Carlsen sees that
line there's no question he will play
Queen F6 and I think that he will find
that this is within his powers very much
so
also look at his way of handing the
situation he senses that this is a very
important moment of the game
he is in full concentration mode there
is however also the other option that
which is kind of tempting to play
something like H6 and after Queen h44
back with the Knight to F6 with a Tempo
black moves away the queen and the idea
of what I had in mind is somehow to go
G6 G5 but that still at this moment runs
into D4 so that's one of the reasons why
this isn't as effective as Queen F6
and a queen trade would be also a
psychological blow to Prague who I think
was just ready to attack right he was in
that frame of mind where I'm going to
tear this guy apart I'm going to use my
queen and generate chances against
Black's King suddenly adjusting yourself
to a slightly worse end game going from
you know a one-sided attack to a long
and arduous defensive task in the end
game is very very onerous from a
psychological standpoint so Queen F6 is
asking to be played and he plays it and
this is a very difficult moment for the
Indian Talent will he trade Queens will
he stubbornly drop back to G4
this is not really a choice Peter he has
to trade and he has to accept the new
reality
yeah which is very unpleasant
then he will be kicking himself of
investing five minutes on King H1 and
missing Black's idea of of Queen F6 this
is a cold shower now for Prague
and the the point is that yes now after
Queen G4 Knight takes F5 there is
nothing to talk about because after E4 I
guess that not even the forcing Knight
E3 works perfectly making sure that
white doesn't have any Queen moves at
all the Knight is hitting also the rook
and one of the lines that computable was
highlighting with whites look on E1 was
that white can count on some idea like
look D6
but at that for that idea it was
essential to have that Rook on E1 eyeing
the E5 Pawn already here black would
just trade that
Intruder easily with Rook V8 and black
is just a very healthy Pawn up so I
don't see another way of
playing with white rather than trading
queens and proc takes his time it's
clear that he is shocked that Queen F6
was possible
and every second that ticks away from
his clock is a second that he could be
spending trying to find the ideal
defensive setup in the end game and I
think that any defensive setup is
connected to the move E3 E4 I think we
will see that move probably he will take
on G6 first and of course Carlson can
recapture several different ways then I
think Prague will advance his Pawn to E4
and try to increase the influence of his
bishop and also to restrict the Knight
on E7 and prevent it from jumping to F5
and harassing that E3 Pawn how would you
assess Magnus Carlson's chances in this
end game there's no doubt that black is
probably the one pushing for a win here
but is it you know 90 10 is it 70 30 in
Carlson's favor what's going through his
mind right now
I think that first of all he's just very
happy uh what happened here in the last
couple of moves he's relieved the at
some point like 15 minutes ago it looked
like he has a very tough position Prague
has the the initiative Prague is up on
the clock and yeah Brock had to go for f
take G6 now Magnus takes htake G6
clearly uh capturing towards the center
and I perfectly agree with you that
somehow E4 is kind of the mood that you
want to play because if you play E4
followed by okay one then eventually
Black's born on E5 will be quite
vulnerable white will have he takes D5
ideas and it's not so easy to move that
knight from E7 so there's a big question
like after E4 is black even potentially
considering a trade on e4
and see that you know what I gonna yes
it's already on the board
Let me refresh
fgag E4 white is fighting for the center
and all ISO Magnus that does he bring
the Rook to d8 which gives white the
chance to eventually Target the E5 Pawn
or is he releasing the tension but make
sure that he fixes the structure
and Carlson has shown you know
throughout his career propensity to to
keep the tension in the center and and
to try to generate Problems by making
the position more complex I think Rook
ad8 is right in his will house on the
other hand if Carlson wants to play with
an abundance of caution if he wants to
say you know listen I know that I've got
some chances here but let me eliminate
all risk first then he will be more
tempted to take on e4 and that is
exactly what he does d takes E4 on the
board it doesn't mean that Magnus isn't
playing for a win the position is still
exceedingly dangerous for white and he's
also asking Prague a very unpleasant
question Peter and White's down to nine
minutes every one of these questions is
going to take more time off of White's
clock what is this question well what
are you going to take on e4 with and
it's not a given that pawn takes E4 is
the best move but Prague plays it he
wants to keep his Knight and he wants to
keep active possibilities connected with
the Knight jumping to C4 and targeting
both A5 and E5 I like that decision from
prognananda
I think this was very important if he
would have traded the knights with 94
he could have been in for a very
unpleasant defensive task
not DTX for DTX C4 exactly because this
vulnerable E5 A5 Pawns
I believe that it should just be enough
to to keep the balance
and the good news is that that Knight on
Nissan is still completely stuck imagine
that this knight from E7 could jump to
C5 they will be saying that black is
almost winning that's uh the Nuance we
are talking about in this position
Black's other idea of eventually going
97 Knight C5 it's also too slow white
only needs one move to get his Knight to
C4
the atmosphere of this game is so
intense uh we've got over 120 000
watching on YouTube a huge huge shout
out to everybody taking time out of your
busy days and watching this epic 2023
World Cup final this is the first rapid
play match game they will play a second
game with the same time control with
colors reversed but obviously if Magnus
Carlson can deal the first blow with the
black pieces ragnananda will have to
beat Magnus On Demand with black but I
really really like the fact that
proctocon E4 quickly he left himself
with nine minutes he left himself with a
lot of time to figure out the ideal
defensive setup and if he defends with
with the Precision that he has displayed
in end games in previous matches I think
he should be able to hold the draw here
yes I also think so but I also get some
information that apparently Fabiano has
a great chance let's get the Bursar View
wow a boss of position is in shambles
yeah now that we know that uh the Magnus
game is a little bit slow and the
situation has calmed on this gave us a
good chance to catch up look at that
gorgeous Bishop on E5 the dark squares
whites Bishop on B3 completely out of
the game
It's a Wonderful situation for black
it's a very one-sided position karawana
brings his a pawn up two squares we
don't even have to look more carefully
at that game it looks like carwana has
everything under control the only
alarming factor is his clock he's down
to six minutes so having updated the
first game of the third place matchup
let's dive uh back into Prague against
Carlson because it's becoming more
intense right the clock situation uh is
dwindling Carlson now below seven
minutes as he decides between the
various candidate moves what are those
candidate moves well Rook a to d8 is the
most obvious but you also pointed out
that C5 square and you can't get the E7
Knight to C5 efficiently but you can
bring the other Knight over through D7
to C5 but Carlson has opted for the more
concrete option he's gone Rick ad8 and
he's hit progs Knight on D2
yes I think that this is a very natural
move because after Knight C4 which kind
of we most probably expect on the other
hand white can also maybe try to keep
the tension but I do feel maybe that
Knight C4 is more natural but what I
wanted to say that after Knight C4
Magnus X on e4 and once you eliminate
that E4 Pawn suddenly the knight from E7
comes to life black will have options to
go Knight D5 or Knight F5 depending
which Pawn white is taking
suddenly black gets a lot of activity
and that's one of the most important
things in Rapid chess
so the move Rook 888 practically A very
wise choice
indeed so Knight C4 tempting but perhaps
keeping the E4 upon alive is even more
important and to keep it alive you have
to keep the Knight on D2 to keep the
Knight on D2 you have to defend it and
to defend it you have to bring the Rook
up from F1 to F2 there's also the move
Rook a to D1 but somehow just
intuitively that strikes me as a lot
more awkward now Rook F2 it does run
into Knight F6 to G4 but then the Rook
could slide over to E2 and you could
chase that Knight out of G4 with H3 so
it's a little bit hard to play this move
but Prague does it again very precise
defensive skill Rook F2 was a very
important move to keep Black's
initiative at Bay
yes super important
making sure that the knight from E7 is
not yet reaching there is also another
argument that not to look F2 it's clear
that white will have some trouble moving
that knight from D2 to C4 because Knight
takes C4 might come with a tempo and for
this reason there are some ideas like
going Knight C8 Knight D6 but hang on
Knight C8 might run into okay F1 isn't
quite threatening to hit that Knight on
F6 and let's not forget about the bishop
on B3 there is still the pressure on the
F7 Pawn as well
yeah Mount Krakatoa there could erupt on
F7 with three pieces attacking that pawn
such an easy detail to blunder because
you think you're out of the woods with
the Queens off the board you're never
Out of the Woods uh when you're playing
a player of prognon on this caliber so
Knight C8 Rook af1 it leads to some
crazy tactics there because black can
play Knight to G4 and try to exploit the
weakness of White's first rank but is
Magnus interested in this kind of
Confrontation no he's not and he's
played Rook D4 but what happens if proc
still plays the move Rook a to F1
what's the idea here well uh basically
there are two ideas he can rely on the
defense 97 to G8 which is a stabilizing
move
uh or is he planning to go for adventure
with Knight xc4 I don't think it's not
magnus's style to go for such tacticals
exactly 97 to GA on the board
but how is he going to untangle this you
want to play B5 and expand on the queen
side let's say Prague plays a neutral
move like H3 and H3 isn't even a neutral
move you're preparing uh to storm the
g-pawn up to G5 and kick the Knight out
of F6 Carlson cannot afford to lose the
F7 Pawn with check what is magnus's
magnus's intended way of untangling on
the king side
is it Rook D7
it's a big question yes uh I like the
movie HD but first proc kicks The Rook
away a nice little touch C3 so black
most probably falls back to D7 yes on
the board already now rookie 2 deserves
attention freeing up the Knight and
preparing Knight C4
and he's done it great play by Prague
here these last couple of moves it feels
like suddenly he's the one who's largely
Out of the Woods here
definitely has improved his position the
Knight is threatening to jump to C4 if
black plays the move B5 which stops
Knight C4 then white can suddenly start
rebooting his Knight to F3 hitting that
E5 pawn and the black has to keep on
somehow defending that
rookie seven Vice Knight might even land
on G5 inserting some more pressure on
the F7 Pawn
it really feels like Carlson did not
squeeze the maximum out of this end game
in the last couple of moves but all
credits of Prague he has once again kept
his composure and he's also kept a Time
Advantage right he's rebuilt those extra
two minutes on the clock and Carlson
probably will go B7 B5 in order to cover
the C4 Square
he might also deploy his Rook from f8
and stack it on d8 but then once again
you have to start worrying about the
long-term weakness of the F7 Pawn
and Knight C4 which is a big problem
yes uh I somehow feel like B5 is the
natural follow-up and b-file Knight FCI
I would even go rookie seven I somehow
sense that magnus's idea was with this
Knight E7 to G8 to somehow set up the
strategical idea of eventually moving
that knight from F6 to D7 and the knight
from G8 jumping to F6 and he has done it
instantly he goes rookie seven
and Knight C4 that is begging to be
played it hits the A5 Pawn will Magnus
initiate crazy tactics there with B5
again that's not really congruent with
his style Magnus trying to keep things
relatively tactics free in this end game
does that mean he is preparing to meet
Knight C4 with Rook A8
probably but it's uh extremely
strange there is this potential weakness
on F7 yes they look on E7 is protecting
that pawn but something tells me that
this is very risky
I don't see yet the follow-up but White
Knight might be able to get to this
extent of course Magnus will kick that
Knight away with Rook d8
I'm a little bit puzzled by magnus's
choices
it's not entirely unlikely that we get
some sort of repetition of moves right
both players might end up being happy
with a draw in this first game from
prague's perspective he's already
survived a scare at the start of this
end game Magnus Carlsen scare came
earlier in the middle game but will
Prague suddenly say hey yeah your pieces
are Mighty passive all of a sudden I'm
up a minute on the clock let me try to
press on the gas pedal big big question
whether Prague will play Knight C4 I
think the answer is likely yes but he
could also make a slower improving move
like King H1 over to G1 or H3 so he's
got quite a few of those improving moves
in reserve that he can play if he wants
to wait for Magnus to put his cards on
the table and he makes one of those
moves Bishop drops back to C2 over
protecting the E4 Pawn
that's a little bit of a surprise
because we kind of talked about the
pressure on the F7 Pawn on the other
hand probably Prague has sensed that
black has enough defenses Knight D7
played exactly Magnus is trying to
reboot his Knights
but
is it not the right time to jump Knight
C4 attacking that pawn at night it's a
different story because after Rook A8
they might be able to jump Knight D6
black isn't able to kick that Knight
immediately out of the game and if you
follow up with the natural Knight C5 we
might be able to start asking some
question to that phone on F7
very interesting endgame on the board on
the board Knight C4 and Rook A8 although
even in that final position we were
analyzing blackstruck could go from A8
back to f8 I'm just not seeing you know
how prod can do more than ask questions
he can pose threats to the F7 Pawn to
the B7 Pawn but it feels like Magnus has
enough defensive Firepower to keep
everything at Bay I think the likeliest
outcome here is a draw but the situation
getting more tense with every passing
second both sides are now under five
minutes so this is at this point the
equivalent of a Blitz game
yes and I also feel there is so much
tension in The Possession because yes it
does look like it's an end game things
have stabilized long terms black can
still be better if black somehow gets
Knight gf6 Knight C5 in
and white is unable to use the moment
for active counter play then slowly
black will start to take over it's a
typical kind of peers peer defense yeah
it's uh long-term issues black has this
lovely Pawn structure if he coordinates
forces then after all let's not forget
that white has three Pawn islands and
black only has two and the Knights will
work beautifully together
and Magnus has already converted a
couple of slight advantages in the end
game in typical Magna style he did it on
demand against Vincent kymer to win the
second match game and force a Ripa tie
break he did it in the second match game
against vasilia ivanchuk in a position
that many thought would end surely in a
draw that would have won in the match
but the fact remains Carlson has shown a
lot of endgame prowess in this
tournament Prague he knows that he
cannot relax he cannot make a couple of
lazy moves and give Carlson's Knights
more activity and G4 what a committal
decision by Prague the engine doesn't
like it he's trying to drive the pawn up
to G5 and restrict the Knight on G8 but
what if Carlson drops into F6 and hits
that pawn
yes and pillbox G5 then the Knight jumps
to H5 suddenly there will be a very
lovely spot on F4 clearly but relies on
some Knight xc5 tactic that the Knight
on F4 will not be able to sit there
forever but then black might get the E5
scaffold the other night strategically
this is a very committed decision
and after Knight G F6 the Knight could
actually drop back to H7 and then either
backward to f8 or forward to G5 and
eventually try to plant itself on F4 but
Magnus he plays Pawn to F6 rather than
Knight F6 that is a huge surprise to me
a very big surprise basically I feel
that it plays into White's hand clearly
Magnus is hoping to go Knight H6 and
Knight F7
exactly and Prague jumps on the
possibility he instantly played the move
Look G2 making sure that he will be able
to meet Knight H6 with G5
and a very risky move followed by an
incredibly alert reaction by Prague
Knight H6 is met with G5 and you need to
play it now because if the Knight gets
back to F7 then black institutes that
clamp on the G5 Square in the worst case
scenario for white is if you allow that
Knight to reach F4 that is the promised
land you have to open up the position in
order to prevent that from happening
this position is going to keep
sharpening up especially if Prague
carries out the G5 Pawn break which
seems very likely given what he's just
played
exactly I think this is what he had in
in his mind when he opted for G4
can we talk about Mutual hallucination
or believing each other that the
possibility of Knight G8 to F6 was was
somehow missed by both players sometimes
In the Heat of the battle it can happen
uh and F6 Loop G2 on the board now white
has everything under control the one can
forget about G4 being a question mark G4
was a very good move if black had to be
if if black had to play the movie F6
and Magnus can't stop the progress of
the pawn by playing G5 himself because
the medicine is way worse than the
disease that would create a massive hole
on F5 white could play Knight D6 or
Knight E3 and 96 would carry a double
attack on the B7 pawn and the F5 Square
so Magnus will have to allow Prague to
open up the king side with G5
he's investing a lot of time here he's
down to two and a half minutes and he
finally decides on Knight H6 frog very
likely to play G5 here and launch an
all-out assault on that G6 Pawn which
will be made a lot more vulnerable by
the fact that the G file will open up
yeah however he's posing he's not
beating out we assume that he might he
he will be very happy that he gets the
chance to of playing G5
and and G5 ft G5 Luke take G5 Knight F7
that's the move that also gives black a
lot of stability the Knight comes with
the tempo hits The Rook on G5
and the look Force back to G3 as you
indicated there will be a pressure on
the G6 Pawn also this 96 Knight F5 ideas
are there but things are heating up G5
on the board
yep and we have that position takes
takes and Knight F7 as you were just
showing Peter the
4g5 and it drops back to G2 and I
thought that Rook G3 made a little bit
more sense but maybe proc trying to
bring his Rook all the way back away
from the influence of black Snipes
looked a bit more natural but uh okay if
you are in Blitz mode rookie 6 played by
Magnus as well making sure that the D6
square is brutally beautifully protected
by the Knight on F7 look on E6 the look
also protects the pawn on G6 and
eventually setting up this very nice
little F6 we have already seen the move
Queen F6 uh which had such a big impact
on the game I I do believe that look F6
also combined with some Knight f8
defending the G6 Pawn is a wonderful
reloading for black the initiative has
changed hands several times in this end
game but that doesn't mean it can't
change hands again Prague now down to
two and a half minutes and if Black's
Knights get active there is still that
F4 Square there is still the D file and
there is still The Rook on A8 which has
not made its presence felt just yet but
if prog takes his foot off the gas pedal
and he lets Black's Knights get active
it's so hard to deal with a pair of
active knights in time pressure the
movement Bishop B3 comes to mind but
case in point you might be running into
potentially Knight D7 to C5 although
there there are some tactics with Rook
takes F7 and Knight takes E5 all of that
has to be calculated carefully and
Prague now under two minutes you can
sense the anxiety both players locked in
concentration
yeah very critical moment
it's uh if if someone just looks at the
evolution bar and see Zero he does not
get the sense that the real feel for
this position this position has so much
spice there is so so a lot of finesses
very crucial decisions for both sides in
the next couple of moves
Rock T2 hitting the Knight directly the
Knight can move but Carlson could also
meet fire with fire he could slide his
Rook to F6 nonetheless and he does and
he offers an exchange of works that
seems to be in Black's favor
Sensational play basically rookie 6 was
connected with this Rook F6 he had to
foresee that The Rook move Look D2 which
keeps the Knight will be made by look F6
everything has would have run into some
tactical issues amazing play by Magnus
and Prague now down to a minute on the
clock he's suddenly down uh two minutes
which could become really important as
this end game continues to sharpen up
white has several ways to keep the Rooks
on the boards he can double on the D
file he can play Rook F to D1 but then
you have to reckon with the Black Knight
getting Super Active on C5
and whites king is not entirely safe The
Rook from A8 could later on it could
slide to the H file and start exerting
pressure on H2 40 seconds for
prognananda as he exchanges Rooks tries
to simplify the position and I like that
decision
I think it was it was the correct call
it's not about fighting for initiative
you just have to make sure that in time
travel with 40 seconds on the clock
you have things under control maybe even
go B4 yes
he is trying to simplify things by Force
exchange pawns make this position easier
to play easier to handle with less than
a minute on the clock and Peter he's
built up 20 very important seconds with
his last two moves
also signals Magnus that you know you
still have that B7 pawn and if I gonna
get 2.2 A5 if I ever think that pawn on
B7 then the a pawn will be way too
powerful
this puts Magnus also on alert I don't
think that he can afford to
to play for the initiative it might be
that it's a dynamic balance
and if he plays them with B5 himself he
runs into Knight to B6 followed by A5 so
it's entirely possible for black to lose
control of this game and I love prague's
last move b2b4 remaining on top and
creating practical pressure on Black's
Queen side as Carlson re-routs his King
toward the center
yeah he's probably setting up ideas like
King E7 Rook d8 trying to trade Rooks
is that a possibility or is he thinking
that if I have the King on E7 making
sure that the anti-squares D7 D6 have
are covered then maybe I will be able to
activate my look on the H file is he
hoping for some counter play
and practice the same he brings his own
King up toward the center and maybe
trying to over protect the E4 Pawn with
King F3 first he plays A5 fixing the
queen side pawns fixing the pawn on B7
uh for a rainy day and Carlson we
mentioned this move earlier he brings
his Rook to the other side of the board
and he's starting to exert pressure on
prox kingside that Rook can dive into H4
and hit E4 and Black's Knights are
rearing to get even more active this
could get out of control for Prague
Who's down to 20 seconds now on the
clock
yeah under some pressure
yeah it's it's never easy to start
defending something
seconds he's gotta move and he does get
10 seconds added to his clock per move
but the situation starting to
deteriorate just a little bit Knight H5
uh oh and the Knight getting to F4
this is getting scary for Prague
the king G2 move was
very unfortunate now he has to sidestep
from from the fork King G1 played Knight
F4 Magnus sensing the moment and the
other Knight can jump into G5 creating
four threats maybe even some mid threats
in some situations
uh oh
just in a couple of friends down to
eight seconds
and look at the speed with which Carlson
is moving every piece becoming more and
more active The Rook coming into H3 it
can drive into C3 and suddenly there are
all these Forks that Prague has to keep
in mind he's got six seconds and Asics a
very panicky reaction as he gives up a
pawn
yeah it is it is a panicky reaction
because because Knight is Knight E5 can
be met by look C3 also Bishop A4 can be
met by Luke CC Knight G5 all this
combination of forces seem too much to
be to handle Knight G5 might be crushing
because if white takes on E5 Black's
King just moves up to E6 forces the
Knight out of E5 and then Knight F3 will
Fork the rook and the king and Magnus
doesn't see it he plays Rook C3 but
Knight G5 now is even stronger
and he plays it and this is almost over
this is over yes because Knight takes C6
can be met by Luke Tech C6 Bishop C6
Knight F3 Fork Prague in a lot of
trouble
Knight F3 the knights are running amok
White's counter play on The Queen side
has not amounted to anything and Carlson
has left himself with three whole
minutes on the clock to figure out the
last couple of touches here black is
completely winning here but Prague will
continue to fight until the last drop of
blood he tries to get the Rooks off the
board but Carlson can play Rook A3 and
there's got to be some sort of a
checkmating mechanism here Knight H3 and
Rook A3 wins the game it wins a piece
exactly
and Magnus pauses because he knows
exactly that yes this is it
let me just be precise
and die yes on the board 9g5 to HD check
no matter where white is going King F1
or King H1 will have the same problem
that lucasri we follow with a double
attack on the bishop Andrew K1 Checkmate
the knights
just Monster Knights
and it took Carlson so much time and so
much finesse to get those nights to
where they are it took a lot of
turnarounds and the initiative changed
hands but Carlson laughs last and he
will last laugh longest in this first
game he will just move his King to F6
getting away from the checks and the
threat of Rook A1 Checkmate and Rook
takes a four forces prognanada to resign
the first game